count by tens starting with 40 fill in
the blanks so let's count by 10 starting
with 4 or count by tens starting with 40
so 40 is for tens so if we add 10 to
that we're going to get five tens or 50
now if we add ten to that we're going to
get six 10s or 60 now if we had 10 to
that we're going to get seven tens or 70
but we don't have to type that in
because they've already put that there
for us but then if we let's keep adding
tens so we had 10 270 or is ten to seven
tens we're going to have eight 10s or 80
add 10 to that you're going to have nine
10s or 90 and then we're done let's do
one more of these count by tens
starting with 656 fill in the blanks
well each time we want to add we want to
add 110 so this 656 it's six hundreds
five tens and six ones well now we're
going to add 10 to it so instead of
having five tens we want to have six
tens so it's going to be 666 666 ones
let's add ten again well now in the last
one we had six 10s now we want to have
seven tens so it's going to be 676 now
let's add another 10 well now we're
going to have six hundreds eight tens
and six or 686 now let's add 10 again so
now we're going to have six hundreds
instead of eight tens we're going to
have nine tens and six ones so 696 now
the next one's going to be interesting
we want to add another ten to this but
how do we have if we add another 10 to
this what do we have in the tens place
well one way to think about this is you
could view 609 tens as 69 tens so if you
have 69 tens and you add one more 10
you're going to have 70 tens so you're
going to have 70 tens and six ones so
696 you add 10 to
you get 706 once again you could view
this as sixty five tens and six ones so
65 tens sixty six 10s 67 tens 68 tens 69
tens and 70 tens 706